greetings apiece assalamualaikum welcome
to the Deen show not just envision this
you're at a movie theater having a good
time and you're looking forward to the
end because there's a villain in this
movie and he's robbed he's stolen and
he's killed and done all sorts of
atrocities so you're looking forward to
the end of the movie for the Justice
you're looking forward to this person
who's now going to get it at the end but
now let's imagine if the film ended and
there was no justice the villain got
away now what are we leading to we're
talking about imagine in this life that
if those who had committed all sorts of
atrocities murder and pillage and rape
etc and the list goes on of evil things
and there was no accountability they
just died would that be fair would that
be right you wouldn't like it for the
movie but what about in this real life
and that is where the concept of the day
a judgement comes in and that's what
we're gonna be talking about here on the
Dean show the day of judgment when we
come back don't go anywhere
this is the greetings a piece of Salam
alaykoum how are you sure it's good to
have you back on the Dean show thank you
it's good to be here always a pleasure
thank you
how was life treating you how's
everything I'm Dalila I'm living now you
know how we do it here you know we get
down to it we really talk about
important issues and I kind of painted a
scenario so people can kind of relate to
what we're gonna be talking about and I
painted a picture of someone at the
movie theater a villain getting away
with killing stealing robbing raping and
at the end we want the plot of the movie
now we want that person to be brought to
justice and if that person wasn't
they'll be throwing tomatoes at the
screen writing bad reviews but then we
equated it to life what about all those
people that have gotten away with murder
and mayhem in this life but in Islam
there's a thing called the day of
judgment so why is it so important for
people to understand this concept
okay smile el hamdulillah host a lot of
cinnamon or a sweet Allah it is very
important to believe in life after death
and we may call it Yokoyama
you may call it a Sarah II may call it
as aljalja America little Hakka is many
many names for that day because it's a
great day in the Sirius day and it is
part of the main pillars of belief that
if somebody doesn't believe in the day
of judgment he could not be a Muslim
even if we pray day and night believing
in the day of resurrection and believe
in resurrection after death is very
important like he stated very good
scenario that you watching a movie and
you see somebody doing all this
criminal eggs all bad things and after
this you get away with it was going to
be the result nobody would like to see
okay also don't forget that some people
in this life they are less fortunate
than others somebody's rich somebody for
somebody have fancy house somebody
homeless so it's going to be anything to
make up for the misfortune of those
people so necessity of believing in the
day of judgment and resurrection after
death it is something very important
he's going to get get there is a monitor
like exactly can you imagine traffic
with no police was no camera with
nothing and everybody driving in
whatever manner that you wish or he
warned so allah subhanaw taala made the
day of judgment for justice and for
those people who show patient they did
not steal they do not commit adultery
they did not forget but they try to
carry the command of allah and live a
decent life so he will reward him
sometimes people do all kind of things
and you can go to a good lawyer pain God
and here you are in the street free
nothing happy but this is different
with allah subhanaw taala his name is
allowed is the mostly just one soprano
italia so we have to believe in the day
of judgment and therefore judgment is
only going to be like a monitor or
something always beeping in your heart
in your mind you're going to die you're
going to be resurrected you're going to
be gathered you won't stand before Allah
it's going to push in you as the
prophets of Allah Allah is saying let us
rule who Kodama abdun had to use around
urbe no human being will depart from the
day of judgment unless he be questioned
about four things he will be questioned
his age his youth his income how did he
earn this money how he spend it you big
question also about your knowledge what
did you learn and how did you practice
we have to be prepared for the questions
and we have to prepare the proper answer
before it's too late
so this life is a field to plant the
hereafter is the time for harvest there
is no harvest here ok there is no time
here to gather the fruit this life is to
try to both the right seed now we get
the result in the hereafter so this is
the necessity of believing in the day of
a judgment is so serious is so great and
you found a lot of Soros a lot of
chapters in the Quran talks about the
name word judgment sometimes you call it
as Angela if there's a little herbs in
xela when the earth quake has this great
shaking or Rajat an arduous Callaghan
and everything is there is out when
Allah say were sure he didn't know my
food so is la Optima beyond Okayama that
Allah swear by the Day of Judgment and
I'll Korea the striking so there is a
lot in the Quran especially in the first
12 years of the prophets Allah Allah
Allah prophethood this what he was
focusing on believing oneness of Allah
believing in resurrection after death
believing in the day of a judgement so
this is something that we need to revive
in our life and always to remember every
day and every day Islam teach you to
remember the day of a judgement a
minimum of 17 times 17 times you say in
your prayer manikyam indeed Allah is the
king the judge of the day of a judgement
so we have to keep this always in our
life in our mind we need to be alert not
once a week not in Thanksgiving not
there
in the beginning of the year but in
every day you have to remember this the
day of judgment and you will say in your
prayer manikyam it D so remember that
there is a day of a judgement and this
person who stole your money it be
brought there this person who Kalia
child will be brought there this person
who gave you a charity and assessed you
he would be rewarded here and everything
will be justice and fair because only
one judge and this Almighty Allah we're
gonna take a break so that's where the
scales of justice will be on the day of
judgement exactly
beautiful we're gonna be right back with
more here on the Deen show please
subscribe to the D show follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
welcome back to the DS show if you
haven't subscribed already make sure you
subscribe we're here every week with
these amazing topics that are so
important
many people are indulging in a lot of
the things that just satisfy the body
but the soul is something that goes on
to live forever doesn't it so now we
have our physical body when we die do we
get resurrected with the same body
because many people they feel like we're
gonna live forever right so now when you
die people think that's it but now we're
talking about the day of judgement so
what happens with the ruction what with
the resurrection what happens to this
soul now and do we get resurrected with
the body and the soul people are
confused over this Islam has all the
answers he's explained this to us
resurrection okay where is the soul when
we talk about soul as the prophets of
Allah still have been questioned about
it was Aluna carnal or the question you
O Muhammad about the soul but allah
subhana wa ta'ala directed the prophets
of allah salem to answer them by saying
color rajim and Urabe say to them
the soul is from the matter the
knowledge of allah you could not get too
much information about it because you
could not visualize it you could not
imagine you could not
you could not determine what it is is
something like understand he says
electricity running in the wire you did
not see this electricity but when you
hook a fan or a mic or a camera now you
can see the result this is the light
okay because there is electricity so the
soul is something yes Israel the
departure of the soul from the body this
what caused the death so you have a body
and you have a soul with the body when
the soul leaves the body now there is no
too much value for this body could not
talk or not speed could not walk could
not do anything okay and the soul will
go in a certain place for a waiting
period 100 years million years
Allah knows best okay but the departure
of the soul from the body this means
death
now they one connected again they will
be connected again that means the soul
will come back to the body this what we
call it resurrection and who call it al
bath battle mode
okay to believe in the resurrection
after death and this is something real
same thing like you see me and I see you
we talking to each other we can know who
this was that okay so this soul will
come back again to the same body that
mean you come back again for the big
question I asked about answer no a nutri
casada does the human being thing is it
will be left alone that we created him
for vain for no reason no purpose does
man think that is not going to be
questioned no Allah will bring you back
again to question you about you dead in
this life okay if it's good or if it's
bad okay
did you believe or disbelieve to some
people although they claim to be Muslims
they believe in motive horrible
something called motive for a call you
know what metaphorical exactly that mean
is not a real resurrection as example is
say some people believe that
resurrection is the resurrection of the
mind okay that you
move from the state of slavery as
example for the black people in America
now they are not slave anymore even they
have a president black okay or
afro-american whatever you want to call
it okay so this is there is Russia
resurrection and that there is status
now they can go to the education you go
to college you go to school you can get
an offices you can you can do that so
this is resurrection to some people no
we believe in real resurrection the soul
will come back to the body these bodies
have been already turned to dust Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala
capable to bring it back and allah
subhanaw taala would make the sword come
back again and everybody will be
standing there before allah in the day
is a day of a judgement and the prophets
Allah Allah Allah missile Yashiro nesaja
fair Aurora or la cámara de na o el
cuñado
man can will be resurrected okay
barefooted naked uncircumcised the same
way Allah created them the day one they
will be brought again and Allah is
capable to bring him back so now is this
something that every messenger that the
Creator sent Allah that every messenger
came with the same warning about the day
of judgement of course yes and this what
we here to prepare and we believe in it
and the f would stop for one second to
think that is a motor vehicle or is not
real that we're going to lose our goal
our target and we could not so what was
going to stop me understand my boss my
manager is not here I can truly
understand $100 out of the counter or
from the drawer and he is not there I
can give you understand some product
from the factory to to my cousin there
is many things that we can do it ok my
wife is not here my parents is not here
why I have to pray but because they
understand you know that Allah sees you
he hears you he going to bring you in
the day of judgement this concept of
believing in real resurrection it has to
remain in our mind in our heart
24/7 the moment you forget about the day
of judgment this will be the loss and
the destruction of mankind as I said the
reason we'll see all this madness and
all these crazy things that happening
that people killing each other people
stabbing each other we will you
understand taken advantage of each other
because this is alive okay this is my
life this is my paradise this is the
first and this is the beginning this my
nd here so let me do the basis that they
can get as much as I can while I'm here
and this is not right but the person
that believes in the Creator believes in
God Almighty Allah he knows that he's
gonna be or she's gonna be accountable
yes that keeps you in checking for
everything even for each word that you
utter it okay ma'am manual for Suleman
calling in led here Illuminati no aware
that your other except is raised to
angels there they were righted to record
it if it's good or bad
and everything in the devil judgment
going to be presented Crockett Arabic a
carabiner secondly on Molokai see read
your book sufficient your book and your
writing you understand and witness again
is you yes
everybody everybody so we're able with
Chuck Noblet if we are able to put
cameras and satellites and we're able to
monitor people that Almighty is a lot
better control everything is being
recorded everything is written
everything going to be presented when
take a break shake and we right back to
wrap it up here on the Dean show please
subscribe to the video follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below you
are watching the Dean show and we were
Shaykh Muhammad say Dudley and we're
talking about the day of judgment
many people now they want to know is
it's closed do we got another hundred
years a thousand years does Islam tell
us now a particular date some people
have guessed it they've tried to guess
it and people have prepared and they've
like you know sold everything off it
didn't come what does Islam have to say
about the day when is it coming are
there some signs a lot of
a lot of places in Quran talks about the
day of judgment under our allah subhanaw
taala saying yes alone akane sriracha a
year animal Serafima anthem in the min
the crow her inner of becoming tan in
the mantle moon zero money of shan allah
is the question you muhammad about the
hour when okay so say that the knowledge
of the hour is blunt to allah subhanaw
taala your job muhammad is to warn the
people against it and they said be
careful be be prepared okay
but when even the prophets of allah
salem doesn't know when but there is
many things out of allah his verses that
he made science okay giving you signals
okay slow down
it's time getting closer getting closer
although to our time is different from
the time of allah subhanaw taala
because as example the way how we count
is different from what allah subhanaw
taala determines the time the prophets
of allah i am said Boris - and I was
dark ahead Ain where Shara be suburb of
a rooster
I've been commissioned or been sent as a
messenger and and the hour
similar to say that there is not too
much time between Z there is no too much
destined between this and that
so if this is the prophethood of the
prophets of Allah Allah which we're
talking about 1400 years ago okay and
the hour he said both of them like this
okay but to us is a long time it's
coming we shouldn't keep ourself and a
man came to the Prophet SAW as I said
when is the hour
say what did you prepare for it don't
worry about when they repair keep busy
and stay on the surah team stock clean
doesn't matter who in but also out of
Alliance mercy that he gave a science so
we can know that it's getting closer and
the closer and the closer give us some
other science please okay
there is the scholars in divides this
science to minor and measure and a lot
of science which is the minor science
had appeared already okay
and there is a major major science now
and all
zim indicates that the day of judgment
is getting closer but the difference
when is the major science appear
repentance is not accepted anymore today
although the some of the science been
the minor signs appear already but if a
person want to be a Muslim will be
accepted if a person doing something
wrong he want to repent will be accepted
but as example when the one of the major
signs is the Sun to rise from the West
and now maybe somebody when he hear us
talking about it say look those people
he crazy talking about Sun coming from
the West
yeah because they have to be believer
first okay all these signs and all these
things Allah has a control over the
skies this moons everything he can do
whatever okay but people in their
calculation everything they said no it's
not okay so if you don't believe in
Allah believing in the power and the
might of Allah you are not going to
accept this but the prophets of Allah
said have told us that the Sun in a time
will come instead of coming from the
east
rising from the east were rise from the
West and in the time no now back can be
helping the person who won't make tawba
so if anybody want to repent anyone to
want to be a Muslim anyone want to get
back to Allah he have to do it now if we
would talk about minor as example is a
lot but I don't think we have enough
time to talk about all the science but
one of them as example which we see it
nowadays
he said about antara fell Aurora I
shared a tower Luna Philbin yet that he
see among the Arab okay those people who
used to be barefooted okay Shepherd okay
they have lofty and whole tall buildings
go to the Gulf go to Arabia go to any of
these places okay you can see okay
towels okay and this is happening so the
last afar Monsieur please be upon him he
said that in this area among the Bedouin
Arabs
yes then you will see them competing
and you're building your Lobby o´clock
buildings yes and is it happening
nowadays we see that that stuff yes the
tiled tallest building now is actually
in Dubai isn't it I know the taller
clock as example about a said that San
Fermin and in Oldham aroma but to to do
a lot of the dwellers of the day of
Hellfire I didn't see them was not in
the prophet time but says they would
have him close after the day of judgment
he said people who have whips you
understand beating the people with it
and said women are dressed but they are
naked and we see among the Muslims not
forget about the kafar among the Muslims
see a woman with the scarf and pants but
you can see all her shame okay so she
dressed but a naked you see she's not
covering herself up properly we see it
he said an arrow through him the
kilometer Boston Maryland over their
head like the hump of the camel they
have this style of the hair what it all
the way up so there is a lot there is
science many signs already already exist
but most of them are minor and the major
science one of the main things that you
have to know about personality the man
dok2 appeal which he doesn't know he's
going to be the Maddy
he's a person whom Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala will guide him overnight and he's
a person yonder Sun will come and they
bring justice in the earth after became
injustice and corrupted okay
Allah will make him good person
overnight and he will fill the earth
with justice okay so this is one of the
appearance how also the coming of a the
Son of Mary Jesus peace be upon him this
is one of the major signs of the day of
judgment and at the shell the Antichrist
okay welcome all right all the things
from the major signs of the day of a
judge tell us before we go and conclude
would what can person be what can a
person do to be prepared for when that
moment comes that now death has
approached and now the soul leaves the
body and now you are resurrected and
it's the day of judgement what advice do
you have for the person who's out there
that they keep your conscience your
conscience sharp always keep this day
over judgement in your mind when you do
anything to anybody okay when you're
dealing with the people when you bind
when you sell and only do anything
remember okay that everything going to
be presented it's time for us to come
back to Allah to be a better Muslim take
care of our responsibilities as a father
as a mother as a principals in the
school as an imam in the mosque
let's try understand to sharpen our
conscience before it's too late
try to get back to to our deal be more
serious and they try to be a better
Muslim than yesterday always trying to
make your day better than yesterday if
you're really serious about your day and
this is something that all the
messengers of God including Jesus Moses
Abraham a super Mohamed or they all gave
that same advice yes yes they teach
about the day of judgment I believe in
in the day of judgment and we all
believe in it and we are have to prepare
for it
as much as we can with good deed we're
out of time thank you so much once again
we didn't even start to scratch the
surface of the subject my god almighty
allah the credit reward you thank you so
what have we gained from this episode of
the deans show that the day of judgment
it makes sense accountability that those
who have transgressed all the limits who
have robbed who have killed who have
gotten away with murder those people
will be held accountable on the day of
judgment and we also concluded that none
of the message all the messengers they
brought pure monotheism they call the
people to worship the Creator not the
creation they gave the good news of
paradise if you obey God and the warning
about the day of judgment and the
consequences if you live a treacherous
life
and none of them knew when it was so
somebody claiming to know when exactly
it is and one story that's linked back
to Jesus when he was even asked when is
this day he said nobody knows neither me
nor the Angels but the crater alone so
this prove that he didn't know and it's
also proves that he was in God but he
was sent by God
calling the people to worship God and
warning them about the day of judgment
and then he also talked about Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him who came with
the same message and also warn people
about the day of judgment so be prepared
for it by doing good deeds by
worshipping your Creator alone without
any associates or partners and living a
good wholesome righteous life and that's
how you could be successful and at peace
and this life and paradise in the next
subscribe if you haven't already to the
Deen show follow us like us keep up with
us on our social media outlets and we
look forward to having you back with us
again
God willing next time until that peace
be with you please subscribe to the DCO
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below